merci Victorin Lurel de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure élu de
la Guadeloupe donc du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain vous avez été
ministre des Outre-mer c'était dans le
gouvernement de Jean-Marc Ayrault on va
évidemment longuement parler de
l'actualité dans les outre-mer mais
d'abord ce plan de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale qui a donc été annoncé
hier par Gabriel Attal et qui cite
clairement les Ultra riches et les
multinationales est-ce que c'est un plan
que vous approuvez bien sûr bien sûr
quand il s'agit de lutter contre la
fraude c'est toujours
utile et même nécessaire mais là c'est
de la comme
il y aura probablement un remaniement
ministériel monsieur Attal de jouer un
peu des coudes avoir une loi importance
son nom bref se faire mousser disons le
très clairement en 2013 on a pris un
texte conséquent il faut en faire le
bilan il faut le compléter et quand
j'entends moi on va donner quelques
moyens on a supprimé près de 1500 agents
à Bercy et
franchement de la gomme
on attend de voir un projet sérieux et
conséquent on ne vend pas les mesures de
augmenter les contrôles
pourquoi pas oui
pourquoi pas
de droits civique ce que nous avions
fait le statut de repenti fiscale la
l'indemnité fiscale les saisies de
patrimoine ce qui n'existait pas à
l'époque les circonstances aggravantes
que nous avions créé à l'époque
notamment la fraude fiscale en banc
d'organiser la création du parc national
le financier il y a la nationale de
moyenne faut-il encore donner des moyens
au service faut pas démontrer les
services publics et en particulier les
services de contrôle il veut aussi que
les condamnations pour fraude fiscale
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas suivies de
détention ça comp de travaux d'intérêt
général Gabriel Attal il dit en plus de
payer son amende le gros fraudeur fiscal
ira repeindre le centre des impôts c'est
une bonne mesure
peut-être mais bon faut que je vois très
mal de très
grosses entreprises depuis des accès à
l'aéroports merci bon
c'est drôle
l'autre actualité c'est toujours la la
réforme des retraites dans une lettre
l'Inter syndicale appelle les
parlementaires à voter la progression de
cette réforme des retraites le 8 juin
prochain lors de l'examen du texte de
liotte à l'Assemblée est-ce que c'est le
rôle de l'intersyndical non je pense
qu'il faut le job c'est à nous être à
l'écoute je pense qu'ils sont dans le
rôle de nous demander à poursuivre la
mobilisation à déposer des textes et à
ne pas se contenter de ce passage en
force personnellement moi je voterai ce
que la liotte a déposer c'est une
proposition de loi transfertizane
je pense que ça peut arriver au Sénat il
faudra
tout faire
mais peut-être mais il faudra tout faire
bien sûr on connaît la posture et la
propension la majorité sénatoriale à
être très proche du Gouvernement sur ce
texte mais on voit bien que le Sénat a
été un peu floué dans l'affaire quand
même puisque le Conseil constitutionnel
a vider le texte des quelques apports
que le Sénat avait pu faire non il faut
tout faire
ce qui va se faire là la demande
d'abrogation est une bonne initiative on
l'appuie
un mot sur une autre actualité du scénar
puisque vous êtes membre de la
commission des finances la commission
des finances qui veut se constituer en
commission d'enquête pour enquêter sur
le fond Marianne qui a été créé après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty et des
questions se posent sur ces attributions
les attributions de ce font par cabinet
de Marlène Schiappa est-ce que votre
commission d'enquête elle a un peu du
plomb dans l'aile avec l'ouverture de
l'enquête du parquet financier c'est
possible que nous ayons quelques
difficultés ce matin la commission des
lois se réunit pour savoir si oui ou non
on peut avoir cette commission d'enquête
la justice c'est en saisie de la faire
il faut voir quel est le périmètre qui
qui reste et qui pourrait faire le
business d'une commission d'enquête en
tout cas lâche pas l'affaire parce que
on estime que on a profité de
circonstances très graves
pour faire de la propagande on lâche pas
la faire ça veut dire quoi qu'est-ce que
veut dire que on trouvera les moyens
au-delà de la commission d'enquête qui
donne de vraies moyens d'investigation
et bien on en restera peut-être à une
mission d'information
on va parler de l'actualité dans les
outre-mer et on commence puisque à
parler du 10 mai puisque ce jour du 10
mai Marc la commémoration de l'abolition
de l'esclavage comme tous les ans depuis
2006 une cérémonie aura lieu dans les
jardins du Luxembourg au Sénat ont fait
le point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire si vous
[Musique]
bonjour Yann
remonte en 2001 puisqu'en 2001 la loi
Taubira était promulguée en grande
taille et la France devenait ainsi le
premier pays du monde a considérer la
traite négrière comme un crime contre
l'humanité on rappelle que la France a
joué un rôle majeur dans la traite sur
les 12 millions d'Africains capturés un
million 600000 ont été déportés dans les
Antilles françaises notamment pourraient
produire du sucre de canne notre pays a
été l'une des grandes puissances
esclavagiste du monde et il faut
attendre 1848 pour que l'esclavage soit
aboli sur tout le territoire il faudra
attendre encore 150 ans pour que ces
mots soient prononcés dans l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale
la France apparaît comme le troisième
[Musique]
la troisième puissance négrière
européenne
elle a donc
pratiquer la traite ce commerce négoce
ce trafic dans les seuls mobiles sont
longs l'argent les épices elle a été
impliquée après d'autres avec d'autres
dans l'esclavage qui transforme l'homme
en captif qui en fait une bête de somme
qui en fait la propriété d'un autre
nous sommes là pour dire que la traite
et l'esclavage furent et sont un crime
contre l'humanité un discours a prononcé
en février 99 la loi Taubira a été
adoptée à l'unanimité très concrètement
le texte prévoit l'instauration d'une
journée nationale de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavage et l'impose
aussi qu'une place conséquente soit
accordée à la traite négrière dans les
programmes scolaires et dans les
programmes de recherche regarde et avec
le temps Steve la journée est
commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavage est devenu un temps fort
politique oui on va voir ces images de
Jacques Chirac et de Nicolas Sarkozy
c'était en 2007 on est au jardin du
Luxembourg où se tient la cérémonie il
s'agit de la première apparition
publique un des deux hommes depuis
l'élection de Nicolas Sarkozy quelques
jours plus tôt images de concorde
nationale autour d'une cérémonie qui
fait consensus même passage de flambeau
même qu'on s'insus en 2017 entre
François Hollande et manuel Macron tout
juste élu et qui ne prendra pas la
parole ce jour-là il ne le fera pas non
plus l'année suivante ni pour les 20 ans
de la loi Taubira en 2021 ce qui avait
provoqué un coup de gueule sur le
plateau de Public Sénat écoutez un
silence peut être solennelle
ceci étant il est quand même édifiant de
constater que le Président de la
République n'a rien trouvé à dire sur
plus de deux siècles de l'histoire de la
France alors qu'il y a 5 jours il
faisait des gammes sur Napoléon
Bonaparte donc on peut avoir on a le
droit d'avoir les fascinations qu'on
veut aucun discours prononcé l'année
dernière non plus par le chef de l'État
lors de la cérémonie cette année c'est
donc Elizabeth borne qui représentera
l'exécutif monsieur le sénateur il y a
un désintérêt de la part d'Emmanuel
Macron il y a des classements symbolique
c'est une évidence et ces politiques et
c'est même honteux je pèse mes mots
parce que le président fait une
hiérarchie et une division du travail
division du travail entre lui-même
président de la République et la
première ministre moi je vais au 27
avril donc je le Cher et vous première
ministre vous allez au vient du
Luxembourg pour mémorer le 10 mai d'as
choisi par tous les élus le président de
la République de l'époque Jacques Chirac
il y a là un des classements symboliques
et quand le président vient ou ne vient
pas ne prend pas la parole donne plus
d'importance à au 27 avril il y a un
problème politique politique
d'autant plus que des engagements
étaient pris par respectés c'était le
mur des noms aux Tuileries qui n'est pas
fait c'était également au prétexte de ne
pas concurrencer le mémorial Act que
nous avons fait en Guadeloupe il n'y
aura pas de musée en terre hexagonale
donc ça n'a pas été fait et puis un
président qui s'absente ou lorsqu'il
vient il est silencieux c'est très grave
ce mépris affiché à l'égard des
outre-mer et d'une grosse et grande
partie de l'histoire de France
comment comment vous l'expliquez
c'est très politique
assombri dans ce crime doit appeler à
l'époque la non repentance la non
repentance il faut pas donner
l'impression on est bien loin du Macron
qui avait été en Algérie dire que le la
colonisation est un crime contre
l'humanité ou le colonialisme bon
aujourd'hui c'est un retour à 180 °c
pour ne pas dire autre chose c'est un
retour complet à 360 degrés
oui c'est la non repentance il faut
éviter de donner des gages à cette
partie de l'opinion il faut leur donner
des gages et donc le président est en
train de nier une part essentielle de
l'histoire de français tobir aladi
survalorisé l'impôt napoléonien
dégradé détériorer déclassé ce qui a été
fait par les esclaves eux-mêmes une
survaloriser que la Porsche algérienne
ou sur le chiriste nous nous nous
comprenons pas ça on a fait si j'ose
dire les
au sein de la communauté au sein de la
communauté des historiens aujourd'hui
c'est le politique qui vient mettre si
je dis jeter de l'huile sur le feu là et
j'avoue que je ne comprends pas cette
indifférence pour ne pas dire sur le
mépris il y a une question aujourd'hui
entre les autres mères Emmanuel Macron
on l'a vu lors des élections mais c'est
plus profond que ça et c'est
indifférence là on a vu le Fast si j'ose
dire donner au 27 avril c'est très bien
parce que nous nous commémorons c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de dates mais
c'est toute la complexité de l'histoire
de France aujourd'hui ne pas venir ou
venir et ne pas parler comme si ce
silence là était tellement sur la nelle
expressif nous on le comprend autrement
je prends un cas précis pourquoi le
colonel de l'gresse qui s'est fait
sauter entre guillemets sacrifié avec
300 soldats pourquoi l'armée ne vient
jamais honorer la mémoire du colonel
Delhaize au fort des graisse pourtant
son nom fort épon pourquoi moi j'ai
déposé une résolution au sein de mon
groupe pour que il y ait une promotion
posthume au grade de général l'armée ne
vient jamais le 27 et le 28 mai il ne
viennent pas on n'a jamais réintégré le
colonel de Grèce qui sait sacrifié au
bon nom de la liberté pourquoi le
Président le gouvernement ne prend pas
une initiative pourquoi je prends ça
pourquoi
l'accélérerontons pas plus rapidement la
le haut Tuileries le mur des noms
ça fait des années qu'on en parle de
plaisanterie manifestement manifestement
gêné et a prioriser cette vision là pas
de repentance et pas de repentance c'est
ne pas salir l'histoire de France ou la
vision qu'on peut se faire dans le monde
alors c'est une histoire qui est connue
la France a participé à ça pour autant
on dénigre pas moi-même j'ai fait
mémorial Act avec une belle majorité
avec le concours de l'état du
gouvernement de la République française
on a parlé de réconciliation il y avait
trois r reconnaissance
réconciliation et réparation il y a
toutes sortes de réparations et moi-même
j'ai évolué sur le sujet la
réconciliation qui d'ailleurs est un
sacrement de l'Église catholique la loi
de virage en parler elle a 22 ans elle
est efficace est-ce qu'il fallait plus
loin aujourd'hui est-ce que cette
histoire est assez connue finalement
on commence à faire du surplace la loi a
été prise bon on a supprimé l'article 5
qui parlait de réparation il est certain
que la question se pose donc déjà
beaucoup de pays qu'une demande a été
déposée par certains pays de la Caraïbe
la France romanticiper ce type de choses
j'ai remarqué ou qui est le président de
la Fondation fait du très bon travail en
apaisement en explication en faisant
connaître et en mise à jour c'est très
bien il faut continuer il faut
poursuivre et il faut que la France
s'empare de cela au même titre que le
musée des arts premiers que Jacques
Chirac a fait il faudrait ici pour que
les Français hexagonaux connaissent leur
histoire mais qu'il y ait un musée ici à
mon sens le 10 mai c'est pas une date
qui est très connue par l'ensemble des
Français c'est une date importante
le président ne vient pas ou quand le
président vient il se tait ou quand un
président symboliquement vient
commémorer ce qui s'est fait le 27 avril
c'est une date qu'il faut honorer mais
c'est vrai c'est compliqué chaque
territoire puisque le décret est arrivé
à des dates différentes il y a eu aussi
des révoltes à des dates différentes
donc depuis Pierre Moreau et François
Mitterrand on commémore en voie de le 27
mais le 22 mai à Martinique le 20 juin
je crois en Guyane et en décembre à la
Réunion bien sûr mais il y a une date
nationale après le rapport fait par
Maryse Condé prix Nobel alternatif
d'origine guadeloupéenne premier
président du Comité pour la mémoire et
l'histoire de l'esclavage bon oui
peut-être mais il y a cette date
symbolique qui réunit et qui qui devrait
unifier l'un par cette présence ce
silence ou c'est indifférence on crée la
un vrai problème politique merci Steve
tout à l'heure on parlera pas voisement
de drapeau sur les mairies et ce sera
suffisamment
on va voir l'actualité chez vous en
Guadeloupe maintenant grâce à Guadeloupe
la première qu'on remercie et on
Laetitia brûlé qui est journaliste à
Guadeloupe la première à deux questions
à vous poser on écoute la première
question
en Guadeloupe l'accès à l'eau potable
reste une préoccupation majeure des
citoyens certains quartiers certaines
communes comme Basse-Terre en ce moment
sont encore très affectés le parquet a
ouvert une enquête préliminaire après la
plainte d'un collectif citoyen alors
monsieur le sénateur est-ce que la voie
judiciaire peut changer la situation
tous les moyens sont bons pour
régler ce problème il prendra des années
avant d'être réglé définitivement mais
lorsqu'il y a eu des fautes il y a déjà
eu des condamnations notamment dans la
ville de Gourbeyre bien oui il faut
aller au bout des choses oui le
judiciaire peut-être et doit être
employé et peut-être très utile sur la
question de l'eau puisque c'est un
problème en Guadeloupe comme dans de
nombreux territoires d'ailleurs du pays
est-ce que vous attendez des mesures de
la part de l'État sur ce sujet ça fait
des années qu'on attend des mesures de
l'État plus conséquent et pas simplement
là aussi de la communication bon il y a
une sorte de brutalisation qui a été
faite et que je c'est vrai un peu
comprise même si
la création la création du syndicat
mixte ouvert permettant de faire figure
élodiement et la région de leur 70% 25%
chacun dans l'investissement et même
dans le fonctionnement on avait demandé
nous 500 millions à l'état puisqu'il
faut près de milliards sur une vingtaine
d'années pour régler ce problème-là on
avait demandé 200 millions subventions
et
à garantir 300 millions l'État a reçu et
l'État avait mis en tout et pour tout 10
millions avec une survalorisation
communicationnelle disons ça fonctionne
communication bon oui on attend encore
que l'État soit là et que l'État ne se
désintéresse pas du fonctionnement alors
moi j'ai eu vous aurez le ministre
bientôt
il y a une gestion qu'il faut revoir
quand on me répond on s'occupe pas de
gestion ni de licenciement abusif ça
c'est fait on s'occupe de l'opérationnel
l'opérationnel se fera le département et
la région font leur isobe ils mettent de
l'argent mais ça prendra des années il
faudra c'est vrai expliquer que on peut
pas régler ça comme ça d'un coup de
maquette magique qui faut une un effort
dans la durée et notamment de
financement qu'il faut de la technicité
de l'ingénierie dans la durée et que
il faudra donc expliquer à la population
oui le tribunal peut aussi faire la
lumière il y a une excellent deux
journalistes de vos compréhension écrit
en excellent ouvrage mieux que la
commission d'enquête qui a eu lieu pour
expliquer l'origine de de tout ça on va
retrouver Laetitia brûlé un journaliste
la première qui a une autre question sur
le sujet des soignants non vaccinés on
écoute
la réintégration des soignants non
vaccinés et imminentes le collectif de
soutien en Guadeloupe exige une
indemnisation une telle demande vous
paraît-elle justifiée et peut-on surtout
y répondre favorablement
nous-mêmes mais j'ai été à l'origine de
changement de vote au sein de mon groupe
mon groupe a bien compris qu'il fallait
demander et voter la réintégration des
non vaccinés
et nous avions une position très claire
Macron là c'était la vaccination
obligatoire Macron a fait autrement l'a
appelé passe sanitaire passe vaccinal et
c'est le sénakia abrogé l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui a bronzé le Pass sanitaire
le Pass vaccinal et qui a posé les
conditions juridiques de la possibilité
ils ont pris beaucoup de temps plus
d'une année c'était en juillet 2022 pour
dire on va réintégrer on a voté ça moi
je l'ai voté pour dire pourquoi c'est
important c'était important parce que il
y a eu une méprise une incompréhension
parce que moi je défendais la vaccin
obligatoire je l'ai assumer j'ai eu des
menaces de mort j'ai reçu des menaces de
mort j'ai assumé ça il faut une
discipline dans une société il faut des
règles et là je n'ai pas que ce qui est
le gouvernement même si la gestion était
catastrophique si on avait pas envoyé
les vaccins Guadeloupe qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait pas entendu ou dans les outre-mer
là ils ont fait le job aujourd'hui il
faut réintégrer c'est une évidence alors
moi j'avais mieux bémol je l'avoue et
c'est la question de Laetitia deux
questions d'ailleurs de dire faut-il
réintégrer oui faut-il affecter
l'affectation des soignants dont les
médecins les infirmiers les
aides-soignants et que sais-je encore
faut-il désinfecter aux chevilles des
malades fragiles et vulnérables
c'est-à-dire des gens qui sont dans son
critiques les gens qui sont
pneumologiques les gens qui sont en
cardiologie etc faut-il les affecter là
aujourd'hui bon l'épidémiologie et et
l'intensité de circulation du virus ABC
donc oui il y a une nécessité de le
faire c'est au chef d'établissement
c'est au gouvernement de voir s'il
désinfecter deuxième chose c'est la
question qu'elle pose sur
l'indemnisation il y a déjà beaucoup de
plaintes de déposer et
certaines ont prospéré des partis ont
gagné parce que la procédure
administrative n'avait pas été respectée
mais pour le moment le le texte pris par
le vin non pas été
sanctionnés n'ont pas été censuré par
les tribunaux en revanche tôt ou tard
peut-être lorsque ça arrive en cours de
cassation ou peut-être un Conseil d'État
c'est selon et peut-être demain à la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne on
peut avoir quelques problèmes et pas
simplement la France beaucoup de pays
ont-ils oui ou non respecté les textes
européens ça on le verra donc c'est le
tribunaux qui répondront à Laetitia
brûlé faut-il indemniser si les
tribunaux qui diront
que faire la crise du covid a laissé des
traces dans les relations entre les
outre-mer et l'État
comme partout ici même dans l'Hexagone
la gestion n'a pas été très bonne la
communication n'a pas été très bonne les
fluctuations les démenties les déni
c'est certain et chez moi notamment
Guadeloupe mais aussi en Martinique un
peu moins sérieux mais dans tous les
autres mains il y a eu cette méfiance à
l'égard d'un traitement qu'il ne
comprenait pas de l'ARN messager bon
donc oui oui il y a eu ça et on a vu
prospérer quelques charlatans sur ça
pour dire oui oui il faut plutôt de la
bon bref
les scores pardon élevés de Marine Le
Pen à la présidentielle dans les
outre-mer ou c'est autre chose ou la
colère il y a eu bien sûr ça qui a été
le le l'apogée si je veux dire de la
politique de Monsieur Macron sa
politique
et marquée au coin de la différence
le réflexe outre-mer n'a jamais existé
la preuve cette affaire symbolique d'un
dîner qu'un président ne vienne pas
sablesse manifestement on ne demande pas
à être câliné faire dans laquelle
inothérapie mais quand même ça blesse
supprimer la représentation
outre-mer pour les élections européennes
le président personne m'avait dit on ne
fera pas ça il l'a fait supprimer
l'abattement d'impôt sur le revenu c'est
taper sur les classes moyennes et l'a
fait supprimer 100 millions de TVA non
perçu récupérable l'a fait supprimer les
les jeunes franches urbaines et il l'a
fait il y a là une indifférence et
abîmer la politique du logement bon
l'actuel ministre des Outre-mer
attendent de faire ce qu'il peut mais
manifestement il y a là une indifférence
certaines n'hésitent pas à dire un
mépris je le regrette
j'ai pris beaucoup là je l'ai déjà
utilisé le mot là j'ai pris beaucoup de
temps parce que moi j'ai été mini je
sais que c'est pas simple le ministère
des outre-merçonnés pas simple il faut
être sa main dans un avion il faut
comprendre 11 12 territoires habités et
voir comment gérer tout ça et comment
traduire sans loi j'ai tenté le laisser
des grandes lois avec des instruments
des outils qui n'ont pas utilisé la loi
égalité réelle la loi de régulation
économique non pas été appliqués alors
qu'ils ont la un arsenal de moyen pour
faire des plans sur 20 ans des plans de
convergence bon ils l'ont pas fait ou
très peu ils ont appelé ça plein de
convergence et de transformation
finalement ils ont transformé les CPER
des contrats de planétarius la
manifestement il y a une incompréhension
totale entre le Président de la
République et les outre-mer on doit
pouvoir on a nommé monsieur carré court
on a nommé monsieur le dit c'était le
plus capé pour le faire à l'époque
quelles sont ses moyens quels sont ses
moyens est-ce que la DG ou que la
direction qui était d'ailleurs une
élévation quand j'ai moi personnellement
transformé en direction pour que de
grands administrateurs viennent
travailler là est-ce qu'il a les moyens
aujourd'hui de symbolique est-ce que la
dgom insuffisamment de personnel
d'effectifs
d'agents de qualité pour faire ce
travail non manifestement donc il y a là
une autre vision pour notre politique
que qui manifestement
hélas ne sera pas
prise rapidement on voit pas les signes
de changement pour être clair merci
victorinurel merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin et je remercie
également Laetitia brûlé de Guadeloupe
la première et toutes les équipes de
Guadeloupe la première qui nous ont
permis de vous interroger qui vous ont
interrogé sur les questions relatives à
la Guadeloupe merci beaucoup Victor